today on the matt walsh show the left
continues to struggle to find a
compromise between their feminist
pro-abortion talking points and their
trans talking points also the white
house refuses to condemn protesters
quote unquote who are planning to hunt
down conservative supreme court justices
and show up at their houses the johnny
depp and amber heard drama continues but
i think the lesson in this story is one
that most people are ignoring so far and
trump allegedly suggests missile strikes
against drug cartels sounds like a fine
plan to me plus the guy who physically
assaulted dave chappelle on stage during
a comedy show will not face felony
charges despite the fact that he was
carrying a deadly weapon at the time
it's almost like they want this kind of
thing to happen more often we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
matt walsh show
[Music]
before we get to the show i have a
special announcement to make as you know
there are very few social events i will
actually go to let alone enjoy
myself at but backstage live happens to
be one of the ones that i actually enjoy
and if it's good enough for me to attend
it's definitely good enough for you so
here's your chance to join me in the
daily wire for backstage live on june
29th at the historic ryman auditorium in
downtown nashville tennessee we've been
on a huge winning streak from suing the
federal government to stop their
tyrannical vaccine mandate to announcing
our 100 million dollar challenge to woke
disney dw kids that makes this the
perfect time to get together and
celebrate another thing we as also is
our best-selling children's book we
should mention as well that should be in
the coffee so come sit and listen and
marvel at me ben shapiro michael knowles
andrew clavin daily wire god king jeremy
boring for our biggest live event of the
year i need the sweet baby gang to be
representing there i need you there i
need your support
so tickets especially because if i give
a shout out to sweet baby gang on stage
this time which i didn't last time my
greatest regret i need to make sure that
there's a response otherwise it's gonna
be very embarrassing so tickets go on
sale thursday may 12th at 10 a.m central
time for daily wire all access members
only and 12 hours later for the general
public if you're not an all access
member don't miss out head over to
dailywire.com subscribe and become an
all access member today daily wire
backstage live at the ryman in nashville
on june 29th see you there
so this has been a difficult uh week to
say the least for the left in fact there
have been several difficult weeks in a
row a few weeks ago elon musk bought
twitter ushering in a troubling new era
where people can use social media to do
dangerous things like you know share
their viewpoints and say their opinions
and then the next week after that my
book johnny the walrus became the number
one bestseller in the country causing
deep trauma to amazon employees and to
leftists across the nation speaking of
which i should mention here
that bookscan the company that tracks
all book sales released their official
list
for the previous week for last week and
we can confirm now that johnny the
walrus outsold every book in every
category last week uh in spite of this
of course it was left off of the new
york times bestseller list it makes
sense i suppose just because it was
literally the best-selling book out of
all books
that doesn't mean that it qualifies as a
best seller
why well i suppose because the new york
times uh and they don't you know they
don't tell you exactly what their
algorithm is for how they track these
things and they don't tell you that
because they want to give themselves the
excuse to leave books like this off of
it but i think what it is is that um
they subtract uh one book sale for every
leftist that your book traumatizes which
means that
by that accounting method i actually
sold like negative a million books i
guess
all of that trauma though was mere
appetizer for the main course which of
course was served this week with news
that roe v wade is about to be aborted
the prospect of fewer babies being
killed even if the decrease will be
relatively minimal as the majority of
abortions are already performed in
states that will not outlaw them just
because roe is overturned but
the prospect is still devastating
for the reasons that we've covered on
the show leftism is the worship of self
through abortion a mother kills her
child sacrificing him on the altar of
the self and thus declaring herself to
be an autonomous independent being it's
all a mirage of course she's just
consigned herself to a life of regret
and despair without knowing it but this
is the doctrine of the leftist religion
and it's why abortion is its highest
sacrament a sort of satanic parody of
baptism
the other thing that has made this news
so difficult is that it comes at a time
when the left has been busy trying to
convince us that biological sex doesn't
exist and men can get pregnant so the
rho news has sparked mass confusion
really on the left some have retreated
back to the
standard feminist no uterus no opinion
talking point
which even though that's now defunct
they're still going with it others have
tried to cut a path
between that and the trans agenda so for
example
the ap yesterday put out new style
guidance and this is the style guidance
that they're giving
they say quote
phrasing like pregnant people or people
seeking an abortion seeks to include
people who have who have those
experiences but do not identify as women
such as transgender men and non-binary
people
such phrasing should be confined to
stories that specifically address the
experiences of people who do not
identify as women
so this is their attempt to come to a
compromise according to the ap
you can still say things like
overturning roe is an attack on women
because you only need to acknowledge the
fictional existence of pregnant men when
you're specifically talking about
pregnant men
this is how the ap seeks to have its
cake and eat it too
and they give it a good shot
but ultimately the attempt fails
either women exclusively give birth or
not and if not then it doesn't make any
sense to say that abolishing roe is an
attack on women now it doesn't make any
sense first of all because it's not an
attack on women but even if it was the
claim is incoherent if men can also get
pregnant i mean you might as well say
that abolishing row
is an attack on people with blonde hair
or an attack on people who are five foot
seven
you would be confusingly and arbitrarily
limiting the conversation in a way that
makes no logical sense
there's no way around it if pregnant men
exist
then all of the standard feminist
talking points are out the window they
are all neutralized outdated transphobic
you have to choose one path or another
choose the path with pregnant men and
penis-bearing women
or choose the path of reality you cannot
live in unreality and reality at the
same time
at least you can't for now
not until mark zuckerberg hooks us all
up to the matrix anyway then maybe
that'll change
but democrats have never been troubled
by their own incoherence which is why so
many are forging ahead with their
standard feminist claptrap and we've
heard many examples of this over the
last few days i want to play one more
because it unintentionally raises i
think
an important point
so here's senator maisie hirono
perhaps the dumbest member of congress
not saying quite a bit um giving her
take on all this listen
i am just gobsmacked i hardly know where
to begin
but fundamentally republicans don't give
a rip about women
they are more angry incensed and
whatever words our outrage by the leak
than they are by the fact that women in
this country are going to wake up one
morning and realize they no longer
control their own bodies i share the
sentiments of my colleagues standing
here and all the people out there who
are outraged by what the supreme court
well the radical right-wing justices on
the supreme court are about to do
so i asked the question is there
anything we can do to men that even
comes close to forcing a woman to have a
baby
i tweeted that out and there are all
kinds of really interesting reactions go
to that tweet and you'll find out what's
happening out there
yes uh go to that tweet and find out
what's happening out there she says um
like i said a very a very very
stupid woman
um
and they're not all stupid on the left
or in the democrat there are
some of them that are quite smart and
very evil um but for mesa arena just a
very dumb person
and she says what can we do
to men that comes close to forcing a
woman to have a baby well again
according to your own party we can force
men to have babies too i mean you know
that's because according to you that's
that's possible but putting that aside i
mean putting aside the fact that
everything
you said contradicts everything else you
say
we have to clarify two things first
um i know these people aren't big on
definitions but by definition
women who get abortions already have
babies if they didn't have babies then
there would be nothing to abort now yeah
we might use the word have to mean give
birth
but
even after a woman has a baby she still
now has a baby so when i say i have
children i don't mean that i am now in
the process of giving birth to them or
that i ever did give birth to them
though i could have given birth to them
according to maisie hirono's party the
point is simply that the child already
exists
once the abortion occurs and nobody is
in favor of forcing women to bring
children into existence
that's not what anyone is saying
but once the baby does exist which
happens at conception
nobody should be able to kill him
that's all
the other part of her claim is what
raises i think the the important point
which is
she says that we don't do anything to
men
that comes close to forcing women to
have babies well
i'll tell you something we do to men
by the current law
a woman can legally kill a man's child
without his consent men are in the
unique position of having absolutely no
legal power to prevent the murder of
their own children in the womb and what
makes this even more outrageous if it
could possibly get more morally
outrageous than that is that is that
though the man has no legal power and no
say at all
as soon as the child is born i mean the
second the child is born he could be
legally required to financially care for
the child for the next 18 years
now
i'm in favor personally of forcing men
to take care of their own children
but i am not in favor of a dynamic where
in one instance uh in one instant rather
the man goes from
totally irrelevant utterly powerless to
prevent the child's execution
to on the hook and responsible for the
child for the next 18 years
and there are a lot of problems with
this dynamic one of them is that the
message that you're sending to men
when the child is in the womb
is that this this uh
you have no power no say it's not even
really yours and it it's it's just an it
it's not even a child it has no worth no
value nothing
and uh it can be it can be killed and
and uh
it shouldn't matter to you at all
and then as soon as the child is born
now you want the father
to
feel responsible
for this being which for the last nine
months you have told him isn't even
human
the whole thing makes no sense
and this is a type of injustice suffered
by men and by men alone
no woman in this country will ever be in
the position of having to sit by
powerlessly while someone else legally
murders her child
now sure there are
uh lots of of men who where this goes
the other way and they are pressuring
women to get abortions that's a horrible
thing too
but many many cases go in the other way
and it's a part of the abortion
conversation which is almost always
ignored
abortion is along with an attack on
basic human rights and the dignity of
the unborn
also an attack on men's rights
you know abolishing abortion does not
interfere with women's rights because it
simply puts women on an even playing
field with men without abortion nobody
of either sex is entitled is entitled
legally to murder anybody
with abortion women possess this power
solely
they are judge jury and executioner the
left is not seeking to preserve women's
rights but rather women's privileges and
this is a privilege that nobody should
have
a privilege that even the person who
exercises it is harmed by a privilege
that destroys everybody involved a
privilege that is in the end more of a
curse
and that ultimately is why abortion
though it grants this evil power to
women alone
it is also an attack on women as well
because it invites a woman to come and
be destroyed
it invites her to give up what is the
best and most beautiful thing and it
makes all kinds of promises
that turn out to be
lies that's what abortion is in the end
an attack on everyone
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well as we've just talked about talking
about a lot this week of course with all
this news about roe v wade the left is
uh is i want to say more enraged than
ever but i don't think they're just in a
constant state of of panic and outrage
all the time but certainly when their
highest sacrament is uh is being
threatened that
brings out a whole new side if that's
even possible that's why it's such a
good time to tell you about um a book
that our friends at 40 days for life
wrote it's the number two amazon
christian bestseller what to say when
the complete new guide to discussing
abortion how to change minds and convert
hearts in a brave new world 40 days for
life is based in texas it's one of the
largest pro-life grassroots
organizations in the world they have one
million volunteers in a thousand cities
in 64 countries holding peaceful 40-day
vigils outside of abortion facilities to
save lives
and help abortion workers leave their
jobs that's why you got to get the book
what to say when today and i said i
should also note there's a lot of great
stuff in the book but right there at the
very beginning is a forward written by
in fact a best-selling children's author
um which is yours truly so that's in the
book as well it covers the old arguments
and the new ones that you might be
hearing at work or with family so get it
now and check out 40daysforlife.com to
help end abortion wherever you live
uh so on this topic of
men and how they supposedly um
you know benefit from abortion and all
the rest of it allegedly i also wanted
to here here's another thing i want to
read quickly this is jill felipe she's a
feminist writer and she just tweeted
this out she says
there are millions of men whose lives
would have been much worse without
abortion men who wouldn't have found
their big loves wouldn't have their kids
i'm sorry what
men who wouldn't have their kids
if there was no abortion
so the kids exist because of abortion
let's try to figure that one out uh
you're in the mind of a leftist it's
just it's impossible to understand
wouldn't have been as successful
wouldn't have taken big risks many of
them don't think about it some don't
even know it
how many men are sitting in elected
office running companies caring for
their much-loved kids going on big
adventures working their way up making
their art writing their books appearing
on your television screen because they
didn't become fathers before they were
ready
now you know the problem here many
problems uh one of them is is that once
again she's ignoring the fact that uh
they were already fathers and then the
child was killed and so
they didn't that's
it's not that they didn't become not
becoming a father before you're ready
that's a that's a good idea
um
but that means not conceiving hr once
the child is conceived that you are now
a father
and when when she paints this kind of
rosy picture she
as always they ignore they pro they
pretend
that regret guilt doesn't exist
it's the same exact thing they do with
people who get
quote unquote gender affirmation
surgeries with you know genital
mutilation where they
they say oh they got that and everything
was everything happily ever after rode
off into the sunset
just completely pretending that the
regret doesn't exist
when in fact millions of people
especially when it comes to abortion
millions of people are
wracked by guilt and regret
and those voices are totally silenced in
this conversation
but the other thing about this that i
noted
was that um
she says
you know since roe v wade there are so
many men who uh they found the loves of
their lives and they got married and
they had kids and they've been
successful
because of abortion somehow
and yet
if you look at the trajectory of these
things what you find is that since roe v
wade
actually there are many fewer men who
are doing those things
fewer men
statistically over the last 50 years
have found their true loves you know
have had kids have been have found
success in life
the rates of divorce fatherless homes
especially for men suicide depression
despair homelessness drug abuse uh
incarceration all of that over the last
50 years since roe v wade has
skyrocketed
now is that all because of roe v wade no
obviously not there it's a it's a it's a
multi-faceted problem and there are many
uh things behind it i think roe v wade
is part of the of the discussion though
it's certainly for one thing
helps to engender this feeling of
despair this feeling of
for everybody that life is essentially
meaningless and worthless
because if that's the statement that you
make about life at its earliest stages
that it's meaningless worthless
you can destroy it and throw it away it
doesn't mean anything
that tends to seep into people's
psyches in ways that they don't at first
notice
but whatever connection there is between
roe v wade and abortion and the ways
that men have suffered over the last 50
years uh the fact is that there is no
evidence going in the other direction
despite what this
geofulopovich might
want to claim um also on the same topic
here you know the last few days some
people who are considered right wing but
really aren't you know they're just
they're hated by the left anyway but
they're not really right wing and i i
don't think i've ever called themselves
that
some in that some prominent people in
that category have spoken out against
overturning roe v wade joe rogan was one
he said
now he took a kind of more moderate
sort of tenuous stance on it and he
questioned whether we should be aborting
babies when they're
more developed but
he did make it clear that the government
shouldn't be getting involved in people
and then also dave portnoy of barstool
sports
there's a clip that kind of went viral
let's uh listen to what he has to say
about it
if that is an issue i'd vote democrat
so it's a great
employee i don't understand
and i thought this in my head two it's
like theoretically republicans are like
less government small government
so like shouldn't republicans be
pro-choice because let the person now i
know the argument yeah you don't want
the federal government making the laws
you want the state but overall the less
government is just let a woman do what
she wants with her body keep the
government out of it that's to me what
that is it's like yeah you can't ban it
if a woman wants it great she doesn't
want it great her choice no government
less government let's cover it that
whatever
it's a crazy thing it has to be said
people i'm sure some people are like
that's not your thing they're gonna be
mad it's a super sensitive issue i don't
care certain issues you have to be like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about this
is one of them
um
so he's saying that he would vote with
people who hate his guts
also people that have that have tried
unfairly to destroy him
uh with various different witch hunts
but i think
when you listen to
portnoy or anyone kind of in that sort
of ideological
category and you listen to them talk
about abortion it kind of goes to show
what i said a few days ago which is
despite the fact that we're told that
this is a great issue for democrats and
that they they would love you know this
is going to create a blue wave on uh
around the midterms and and uh
and this is going to backfire on
republicans
despite that claim it's actually not
true because
they do not want to talk about this
this is not a conversation they want to
have which is why they're always trying
to change the subject to something else
let's talk about let's pretend that this
is an issue of you know interracial
marriage as eric swalwell said or joe
biden said yesterday next thing we're
going to be segregating
gay kids from straight kids in the
classroom or something because of roe v
wade doesn't make any sense but they're
just they're desperately trying to it's
like when roe v wade comes up when
abortion comes up they fall into this
hole and they're just clamoring on the
sides of the hole to climb out of it
because they they don't want to talk
about it
why don't they want to talk about it
well because
their position is is hideously immoral
and terrible but also because
they rely on
kind of what you just heard there
which is
you know what you hear from dave portnoy
it's pretty clear to me
that he just hasn't
thought about this issue hardly at all
this is not someone who's given it a lot
of thought
and so what you hear from him on
abortion it's kind of like the same
talking points that
you hear from somebody high schoolers on
on a topic like this
and that's what they want that's that's
what the pro boards want that's what
democrats that's what the left wants
they know that it's
that
they're in a good position
and the best thing for them
is when you just don't
think about the issue very much
which is why they don't want to spend
multiple news cycles or even one news
cycle talking about it because when you
talk about it it forces people to think
about it
for dave portnoy it's pretty clear that
he kind of kind of indicates that that
this is
you know it's not his issue he hasn't
thought about it but like since it came
up here's his thoughts just kind of off
the cuff
and they're very they're they are they
are very uh undercooked let's just say
and that's what they that is what they
depend on when you look at this the
polling results of 70 of americans
support roe v wade well most of them are
in kind of that category they just don't
they don't understand the issue they
don't think about it
and that's where the left wants you they
want you not they want you not thinking
about it because when you do think about
it for just a few minutes
you start to see how absurd this kind of
claim is that well the government
shouldn't control what people do of
course the government controls what
people do something i mean there are
things that people want to do
that they should not be allowed to do
that we should try to prevent them from
doing and if they do it they should be
punished for doing it
so that talking point just doesn't make
any sense let women do what they want to
do well no of course we're not going to
just let women do anything they want to
do
there are there are lots of things that
a woman or a man might want to do that
that any normal person
any civilized society would say you
can't do those things
uh
theft rape now of course in many cities
in america you can do a lot of those
things especially theft they're not
going to punish you for it but
again most normal people look at that
and say well that's crazy you got to do
something to stop that
another one of those things is murder we
don't allow people to murder other
people
should we make an exception if you're
murdering your own child
not only should we not make an exception
but that's actually the worst kind of
murder
which again if you think about it for
like two minutes just spend two minutes
thinking about the issue that will
become very clear to you
which is why they'd not want you
thinking about it for even two minutes
instead they want
half-baked thoughts they want you to be
emotional and they want you to be angry
and that was especially clear um
yesterday at the white house press
conference jenn pasaki who
i think this was her last day she
introduced her replacement and she has
now gone off to become an msnbc analyst
again no conflict of interest there
she's just been she's been doing this
job
while also working out a gig where she'd
become co-workers and colleagues with
the very people who are supposed to be
holding her to account so no conflict of
interest but i think she's gone now um
this is
her last press conference
and she was asked about
quote-unquote protesters
who are tracking down the home addresses
of the conservative supreme court
justices to go to their homes to
intimidate them
is jen pasaki speaking for the white
house willing to
come out and clearly denounce that kind
of thing
well what do you think let's listen
these activists posted a map with the
home addresses of the supreme court
justices is that the kind of thing this
president wants to help your side make
their point look i think the president's
view is that there's a lot of passion a
lot of fear
a lot of
sadness from many many people across
this country about what they saw in that
leaked document we obviously want
people's privacy to be respected we want
people to protest peacefully if they
want to to protest that is certainly
what the president's view would be so he
doesn't care if they're protesting
outside the supreme court or outside
someone's private residence i don't have
an official us government position on
where people protest i want it we want
it of course to be peaceful
there's no we have no official
government position on whether you
should be going to the homes of supreme
court justices to try to intimidate them
to change their opinion on uh on a case
she has no position on that
when in fact really what that means is
that she does have a position and the
opposition is yes please go do that
because
and but this is uh remember if you you
know january 6th was the worst day in
american history it was like 15 911s and
seven pearl harbors all rolled into one
and here she is refusing to denounce
refusing to tell people hey no do not do
this
and in fact if you do it we're gonna
we're gonna arrest and prosecute you
because
she wants them to do it
i told you when this news first came out
they will on the left
and this is generally the case for
anything they want but especially when
it comes to this they will do anything
they will do anything
and
look when you send people to supreme
court justice when when you first of all
because let's follow this the steps here
first you tell people
that overturning roe v wade is an attack
on the very exist their very existence
it's an attack on their lives on their
basic fundamental human rights
okay it's gonna turn it's gonna turn
women into slaves
so you tell them that
and then they get the addresses for
supreme court justices and they go to
the home
where these people live
and all you say about is hey well you
know protest however you want
you are all but inviting people to
not just intimidate but to violently
physically attack supreme court justice
and the thing is if um if someone takes
all this very seriously
what if somebody really believes they
actually believe that overturning roe v
wade means the enslavement of women they
really believe that
well then they would feel totally
justified in actually just assassinating
murdering
the justices who are about to enslave
women
i mean think about it if it was if it
was actually true
that there were
people in positions of authority who
were about to enslave
half of the population
then
pretty much any
you could go to you could be morally
justified in pretty much any means
necessary to stop that from happening st
to stop the enslavement of of half the
population well
it would be hard to go too far in
stopping that from happening
so you tell people that
send them off to the house
where the supreme court justices live
i mean you know what you're doing
and if
one of these justices are actually
killed
i guarantee you no one in the democrat
party none of them
are going to have any regret they'll be
perfectly fine with that
and i'll tell you something else they
would actually be hesitant to even
denounce that
i mean justice alito could be killed by
an angry mob
and
the democrat party would be very
hesitant in even denouncing that
because that's what a lot of these
people want
just do whatever it takes
to make sure that we can still have
abortions anywhere we want
that's how important it is to them
pure abby it's pure unadulterated evil
is what it is
all right let's move to this
a lot of people tracking this amber her
johnny depp situation johnny depp suing
for defamation
um yesterday amber heard i guess two
days ago she she took the stand uh to
you know respond and
in her own defense against the
defamation charge and here's one clip
that's been making the rounds online you
know a lot of people think that that
amber heard is kind of overacting and
they they don't find her to be a
credible witness so let's watch
some of this
we get an argument and i shove past him
just stomp off
and he grabs me
we have an argument about
me walking away am i walking out of this
and in my head i was like i
i would i actually wasn't thinking of
leaving yet but
that would later be going through my
mind
and
we had a
a brief interaction and i don't
i don't
remember the exact
sequence of things
i wish i did
i have a lot of flashes
it gets a little bit more confusing from
my ability to recall
everything in a linear way a little
later on as things got crazier
but for this part the first night
what i distinctly remember
is at one point i i i don't think i had
gotten very far maybe i came back into
the room
but he when he shoved me
i went flying across these parakeet
floors i mean just skidding
across these floors
and i remember thinking it just looked
so easy for him to
throw me around like that you know i i
i i i just slid
screeching my skin against this like
beautiful wooden floor
uh that's a
interesting thing to note and when
you're telling the story that the floors
were beautiful
uh now keep in mind that we also have
and johnny depp on his defense had audio
of amber heard admitting on tape that
she had attacked him and actually
admitting that she'd hit him and then
calling him a baby
for uh complaining about it now
so it's it's hard to square those two
things on one hand she paints this
picture of this violent monstrous
guy who's throwing her around like a rag
doll
but on the other hand we have her on
tape admitting that she smacked him
around and then making fun of him would
call him a whiny baby like is that what
you would do if somebody was if it had
so much more strength than you and they
were prone to these violent outbursts it
just doesn't doesn't make a lot of sense
a lot of this doesn't make any sense
and um she also is kind of an
interesting thing where there are things
that she remembers very like little
little details she remembers very
vividly and then other things that you
would think are pretty big details that
you can't remember
um and then
a lot of um
what would appear to sometimes be on the
stand some some acting going on
uh but here's my point this is what i
said before i just i want to
re-emphasize this once again
um
having tracked this just a little bit do
i think that amber heard
is
the good guy
in this scenario
obviously not i think it's pretty
clearly not we know enough about her
we've heard enough and there's enough
evidence to know that she's she's not
the good guy
does that make johnny depp the good guy
though and the answer is
no okay what this is is that th this is
a this is a these are two hollywood two
self-centered
egotistical hollywood dirt bags
who
found each other and frankly like richly
deserve each other
there's no good guy there's no real side
to take here and that's what i don't
understand is the people that are i want
johnny depp's i don't know what amber's
hurts if you have tracked this at all
paid attention to it all how can you
listen to any of this and come away
feeling that either of them are
sympathetic characters
makes no sense to me
you know what the lesson here is
look johnny depp
was
married to a woman
left that marriage
and then was with a a succession of
different women and i think he was
engaged a few times and then broke that
off and then and then he had he had kids
with a woman
and he uh left that i'm not sure if he
ever actually got married but he left
the mother of his kids and landed on
amber heard and
we know how that worked out
and so what is the lesson here
among maybe many other lessons
one of them is that
when you keep
trading in
a partner or romantic partner for
another a newer model
you're not going to find that the
quality
of the newer model
um
improves over time usually it's going to
go the other direction
and ultimately for
johnny depp
you know especially if you if you've
left marriages you've left your kids
you've done this and that
um
the woman that you end up with at the
end of that whole succession is going to
be the sort of woman who is willing to
be with a man who's done all of that
and that's not going to be a high
quality woman
um
and especially if you're
older and rich then she's going to have
other intentions in mind
so maybe that's the lesson in all this
maybe you find here
something we could all consider doing
take this as a
as a word of warning here take this as a
as an example of what not to do instead
um find one person
and you you get married to them
and you have a family and you stay with
them
because once you leave that person and
embark
on this journey
you know it's
you're not going to land on somebody
better
it just keeps getting worse and worse
and worse as you go
i think that's what i would take away
from this not that uh johnny depp is a
you know
the innocent victim in all of this
because that's not how i see it at all
uh
let's see what else do we have
this is from fox 13.
no surprise here unfortunately a man
accused of attacking comedian dave
chappelle on the stage of the hollywood
bowl tuesday evening will not face
felony charges according to the los
angeles time the 23 year old man was
originally arrested for assault with a
deadly weapon after rushing the stage
authorities told the los angeles times
that the man did not brandish the weapon
during the assault
the los angeles district attorney's
office has forwarded the case to the los
angeles city attorney's office which
handles misdemeanor crimes within the
city uh spell was performing on stage
for a netflix comedy special when he was
assailed it did not appear he was
injured by the assault so
this
this is someone who rushed on stage in
the middle of this comedy festival and
tackled dave chappelle to the ground and
had a deadly weapon on him he had a
knife that was oddly enough hidden
inside a replica gun that part i don't
understand well i do understand it this
guy's a lunatic so there's a lunatic who
physically attacked dave chappelle on
stage had a knife on him
and the los angeles district attorney
desperately looking for any reason
you know to um
let a violent criminal off the hook what
they're saying is well he didn't
technically brandish the weapon he just
had it on him
and who knows if he intended to use it
you know this is a crazy guy who rushed
the stage during this comedy special
tackled somebody on the ground had a
knife on him well but we don't know if
he was going to use it he maybe had the
knife who knows maybe he was just before
that he was cutting apples with it and
that's why he had the knife for a snack
he was slicing the cheese and apples
so that's a misdemeanor charge
if you're wondering why our cities are
plagued by crime um
this is the reason why and there's
there's just
you don't do that
you don't let somebody like that off the
hook with a misdemeanor
twist twisting yourself into logical
pretzels here to to justify making that
a misdemeanor crime you don't do that
unless you want more crime
which
in the end is what these people actually
want
and i think they also want i i think
especially on the radical leftists
they are especially happy with a
scenario where comedians on stage now
have to worry especially if you're in
california
you know you have to worry about what
you're saying because if you say
anything if you tell a joke somebody
doesn't like they could just rush the
stage
and assault you
because now we have two high-profile
examples of that happening of a comedian
in a span of just a few weeks
a comedian being assaulted physically
assaulted on stage and in one case there
were no criminal charges the other case
may be a misdemeanor although they
haven't even confirmed that there will
be a misdemeanor charge there might be
no charge at all
so again you don't
you don't do that unless you actually
want more of that kind of behavior which
is what you're going to get
telling people words are violence jokes
are are harmful
and then also letting them know you know
with a a wink and a nudge that hey
if you assault a comedian on stage
maybe you'll get a fine at most
all right one other quick thing this is
a headline from forbes i'm just going to
read the headline says trump wanted to
secretly launch missiles into mexico to
blow up drug labs according to
ex-defense secretary
who reportedly made this claim
and this is something people are upset
about it's supposed to show that that
trump is a is a crazy person i guess
they wanted to launch the missiles and
blow up cartel labs in mexico
i think it sounds like a pretty good
idea although trump should should know
that we don't launch missiles and blow
up drug cartels we don't do that in
america
we would never i mean launching this is
some of the people that were outraged
online yesterday were saying oh trump
wanted to launch a missile into a
sovereign nation
what kind of president would do that oh
i don't know every president we've had
for the last several decades has been
launching missiles and talk into
sovereign nations
obama
was loved that
drone strikes missile strikes
he couldn't get enough of it
but what what trump should know is that
uh no we don't blow up
and this is the lesson we learned from
biden and from other past presidents uh
we don't blow up drug cartels instead we
launch missiles into middle eastern
countries and we blow up innocent
families which is exactly what biden did
and of course
no one held accountable for that either
well mother's day just around the corner
it's time to start thinking about what
you want to do to make your mom feel
special and in fact you probably should
have started thinking about that way
before this moment right here on friday
but um you know i've been trying to
think about what i want to give my mom
this mother's day season all i can think
about is the time where i refuse to fix
her vhs player over this past holiday
season uh of course i don't apologize
for that because really i was doing my
mom a favor i'm trying to tell her like
you know let's let's get into somewhere
within this century at least
but that's why i want to give my mom
something that she'll be thanking me for
instead i'm going to give her a reason
to throw away that vhs player once and
for all with legacy box legacy box is
the best company out there when it comes
to digitally preserving all of your
sentimental uh but outdated belongings
that's why they've helped millions of
people digitize their belongings over
the past decade just send legacy box all
your video tapes film reels photos and
their team of over 200 trained
technicians will hand digitize
everything you can track their progress
along with their online tracking system
and uh once they're done they'll send
you all of your original copies along
with digital copies stored on a thumb
drive the cloud or dvd now my mom won't
have to worry about having a working vhs
player anymore and she can show all my
embarrassing photos and the videos to my
wife easily over the holidays you could
do the same for your mom this mother's
day by visiting legacybox.com walsh
right now to get 60 off your order
that's legacybox.com
walsh let's get now to the comment
sections
[Music]
caleb says
uh in reference to the opening topic
yesterday to be fair young children are
asexual but what but that changes around
puberty which brings us back to the
first question why would you discuss
this with kids yeah a few people in the
comments made this point somebody asked
you know why would i have a problem with
kids identifying as asexual as at least
one of the kids in that groomer art
teacher's class did because he made an
asexual pride flag to represent himself
and i you know i made a i pointed that
out yesterday on the show and and said
that that's
another disturbing element of this that
there's a kid you know kids identifying
as non-binary and then kids identifying
as asexual
what what's the problem with that
because as you point out well especially
young kid before puberty that's
essentially yeah it's true that kids
should be in effect at least through the
early stage of their life asexual that
is like not thinking much about sex
but here's the point
that's not an actual identity okay it's
not a label that you want them to take
on
i don't want my kids to my kids to go
around actually saying i am asexual they
have an asexual pride flag that's
extremely disturbing that's not what you
want kids
and you especially don't want them to
adopt asexual as an identity that
belongs under the lgbt umbrella because
putting it there it doesn't make any
sense anyway you're
what we've done is we have we have
sexualized asexuality by including it on
the in the lgbt club
so the whole thing is absurd but that's
not what we want for our kids i don't
want my kids to identify as asexual
marching under an asexual pride flag
this is my identity i'm proud of it
no no no no i just want them at this age
to not think about that stuff at all
i want them to that to not be a part of
their lives right now
it need not be
and for generations and generations of
kids through the whole history of human
civilization it wasn't until now
not because you had like nine-year-olds
back in the 50s who were all identifying
as asexual not at all
you just didn't think about it was not
part of their life
so i did not consider that an
improvement at all
gail bishop says i love it when you
talked about someone having a road to
damascus moment and seeing the light
however it also made me sad to think
given the lack of religion and faith in
today's world how many people heard
these comments and then scratched their
heads and said huh what did that mean
well it's also the consequence of uh and
i think about that every time i make a
biblical analogy or reference or you
know even if it's something as should be
as well known and famous as a road to
damascus moment
it's also a consequence of not teaching
the bible in schools
which obviously it should be obvious
anyway the bible should be taught in
schools including in public schools not
just in private christian schools
it should be taught because it's the
most influential
along with being i would say as a
christian holy scripture along with that
it's also the most influential piece of
literature ever written hands down
nothing even comes close
and uh there's just so much in other
kinds of literature that you can't
understand in other stories there's you
know in language in metaphor there's
just so much you can't understand
until you have some familiarity with the
bible
um
let's see
i have to disagree virginia
says i have to disagree with matt on the
idea that we don't need god or the bible
to be pro-life human life at any stage
is only valuable because god said so
if there's no god then we're all
accidents and life is meaningless if
there is no god that there's no
afterlife so there's no pressure to do
right because the time you have on earth
is short and there'd be no god to answer
to the pro-life argument has to be built
on the foundation of god
any other is not sound enough
yeah it's true that
when you go deeper
into the pro-life argument
um you are eventually going to get of
course to the reality of god that's true
in any
conversation i mean literally anything
you talk about if you go deeper into it
and you dive all the way down
at the bottom of everything you're going
to find the reality of god so that's
that's true
um
the question though is whether if we're
having this discussion
you know on um
with a sort of general audience
do you lead with that
do you lead with
abortion is wrong because god says so
and and i would say absolutely no that
is not what you lead with
it's you can you get there like first
you have to get them on your side on
abortion and that life has inherent
value that it's wrong to kill people
because if you start with well god says
so well then that brings you if this is
someone doesn't believe in god well okay
now we're taking a detour and first we
have to argue because that's not gonna
mean anything if they don't believe in
god that means nothing to them
absolutely nothing
so if you're talking to someone who
doesn't believe in god or hasn't really
thought about it whatever and you say
abortion's wrong because god says so uh
okay that now now the conversation
becomes is there a god and so now you
have to now now we've gotten away from
abortion which is which is which is a
very winnable argument
and now we've gone over to god which is
also a winnable argument but it's it's
it's a much more complicated argument
and um now you have to get them on your
side with that and then you can circle
back to abortion so you've just taken
this huge detour
uh and basically i think let the pro
aborts off the hook
so
that doesn't need to be your starting
point
and if this is someone who believes for
example
that it's wrong to murder innocent
people
as almost every person in the world at
least in theory believes that
then that can be your starting point
and you build from there
well great news to reiterate my lgbtq
plus masterpiece of a book johnny the
walrus was the number one bestselling
book in america last week this means i
am not just a very important voice in
the transgender conversation but a very
important voice
in america its first printing saw it
sell out in less than 24 hours and
seeing how obsessed the left has been
with his existence i'm sure it will
serve as an inspiration for the entire
lgbtq plus community for centuries to
come especially as we get next month
into lgbt uh pride month that's gonna be
a time especially when i think it's
gonna be good to have this book in
circulation so if you haven't gotten
your copy yet now is the time head to
johnnywalrus.com to buy your copy right
now now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
for our daily cancellation today we turn
to the huffington post which for one
thing still exists that's the first bit
of news and the second is an editorial
on the site which has been making the
rounds online over the past week or so
it's written by somebody named kelsey
smoot who's a man i believe a bit of a
shot in the dark i'm not sure but uh he
provides us with this bio
um kelsey they them theirs is a phd
candidate in american studies their work
and writings explore the process of
identity formation at the nexus of race
gender and sexuality they are a cultural
and gender theorist a writer and
advocate and a poet having grown up by
coastal and spending the majority of
their adult life in a state of
transience they drew from their eclectic
life experiences both deep fear and
great optimism regarding what people are
capable of
now should give you a pretty good idea
about where this is headed uh though i
must acknowledge some gratitude to
kelsey for exploring the nexus of race
gender and sexuality very few people
have the vision and courage to really
dive in and study the intersection of
race gender and sexuality when i say
very few people i mean you know it's
only him and every other college student
in the western world
i mean students in china are all
becoming math geniuses and rocket
scientists our students are all getting
their phds in queer theory
all that to say we certainly needed one
more person to think and talk about race
gender and sexuality so i'm grateful he
was up to the task and he clearly
applied all of this expertise while
writing the huffpo article in question
titled
if you think my pronouns are optional
we can't keep being friends
now i'm tempted here to simply say
okay great bye
but that would make this segment a
little bit too short so we'll trudge on
he wrote
uh lately i've been embroiled in what
feels like constant conversations about
pronouns the wrong ones the right ones
the preferred ones hint that third
category is defunct
yes please update your rule book the
term preferred pronouns which has been
shoved down your throat relentlessly is
now defunct not only defunct but
offensive the very people who invented
the term and demanded that you use it
are now demanding that you not use it
because it's offensive they've suddenly
decided why is preferred pronoun
offensive well presumably because the
qualifier preferred doesn't carry the
weight that they want it to it makes the
pronoun sound optional
but as the title the piece declares
pronouns are not optional they are
utterly necessary
if you don't use somebody's pronouns
you'll you'll kill them they will die
right there on the spot they'll shrivel
up and melt away like the wicked witch
pronouns are no mere preference they are
necessities like food water oxygen
pronouns are the very air they breathe
this is the claim anyway and it puts
into context the rest of what we're
going to read here continuing
as a non-binary trans person who uses
they them there's pronouns as my terms
of address i suppose i should be
celebrating this influx of discourse on
the proper usage of pronouns truthfully
i'm exhausted
okay we're going to leave aside the fact
that non-binary trans makes no sense i
mean these labels individually don't
really make sense but combined they
somehow make even less than zero sense
also note how kelsey declares himself to
be exhausted
common theme on the lgbt left you
remember that college student last week
who said he was exhausted because i was
giving a speech on campus
people who've never exerted themselves
who have lived coddled lives of unending
comfort who've never even attempted to
achieve anything of significance are
somehow exhausted
not that i doubt their exhaustion by any
means i fully believe that it's
exhausting to go through life so utterly
self-absorbed
to think that everything revolves around
you to constantly be on the lookout for
slights and offenses to be offended all
the time by everything and everyone
everywhere
this is extremely exhausting of that i
have no doubt
indeed this is one of the reasons i
could never be a raging narcissist i
just don't have the energy for it
continuing
in the six years since i've come out
i've witnessed the concept of pronoun
inclusivity shift from fundamentally
martian to hotly contested on the macro
level pronouns have become a cultural
battlefield an email garnish a token
signifier of righteousness for
organizations who want to rebrand
themselves as politically savvy and
inclusive he's right about that part
personally within the several of my
closest relationships the fact that i
require ungendered pronouns when
referring to me in the third person has
become the source of deep strain and
disappointment i feel duped by some of
the positive reactions from my friends
and loved ones when i initially came out
as trans mask
non-binary
in retrospect that was the easy part i
was the only one changing in the years
since i've come to find that i'm in
constant competition with my past
for a while i flinched when i was
misgendered but said nothing
then i began giving gentle reminders
followed by long-winded overtures of
understanding i felt guilty and
embarrassed
and made sure to emphasize emphasize
that effort was all that mattered to me
recently though i've begun pushing back
you'll have to do better is my new
refrain
now of course the proper response to
somebody who says you'll have to do
better regarding their pronouns would be
words to the effect of
oh yeah well you'll have to kiss my ass
you smug little [ __ ]
but unfortunately kelsey has not been
given the gift of that sort of honesty
instead those closest to him have
apparently tried to accommodate his
demands and even apologize profusely for
the times they slip up and accidentally
use proper grammar
that's not good enough kelsey says he
demands absolute perfect compliance from
everyone
100 of the time
or else he'll stop associating with them
which of course sounds more like a
promise than a threat to me
but reading a bit more here he says
as i think more critically about these
conversations i feel regret about the
moments where and i have avoided asking
the hard questions that cut clear
through the facade of language the
resulting friction from these
interactions has has had negative
consequences in my relationships
i feel myself withdrawing from people i
love avoiding interactions that might
lead to misgendering and shrinking in
conversations that once felt safe and
enjoyable inversely i've been told that
spending time with me feels more
cumbersome now
shocking in addition to long-standing
relationships new connections are often
marked with a similar tension regarding
my pronouns the idea of having to lose
some of the people closest to me the
folks who have helped to shape me and
the person i am is devastating however i
consider having access to me my time and
my company to be a gift not a given for
anyone in my sphere
i'm clear my inherent worth as a person
despite all the ways in which society at
large devalues me
to be frank this process of change
requires concerted effort
to be franker i think that trans and
non-binary people are worth the effort
well if i could be frank myself kelsey
allow me to say this
um no
you are not worth the effort
at all
i mean your unbridled untamed unwielding
narcissism
unyielding and unwieldy narcissism has
turned you into a burden a strain on
everyone you know
you're not nearly smart or interesting
enough to make dealing with you and your
nonsense worth that kind of effort
you're an irritating tedious boar who
compounds the problem by also being
psychotically self-centered
but i'm grateful at least
that you have so convincingly
illustrated and proven a point that i've
made many times in the past which is
that this whole preferred pronoun thing
is nothing more than passive aggressive
manipulation a power play
by attention-starved egomaniacs like
yourself
you want to be affirmed all right but
you want to be affirmed as the center of
the universe the main character in this
production called life
you demand to be affirmed as the central
figure in everybody else's lives
you can't simply be around somebody talk
to them spend time with them you need to
be constantly reminded and you need them
to constantly remind themselves that you
are better and superior and more
important and more interesting
that's what the pronoun game is all
about
and that's why i hope to god one day we
cross paths so that i can perhaps be the
first person you've ever met to look you
in the eye and tell you i don't give a
damn about your pronouns
i will use whatever words i want to use
i will refer to you however i want to
if you could believe it
i will call you anything i want to
and there's not a single thing you could
do about it
because you have no power
over me anyway
also
of course you're canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin